Welcome to ABE Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
I almost busted in to replace the Alan with Spy, which is my, I'll talk to our guest
about that in a minute.
I don't know if we ever got to that before, but I have, Brent's not here.
Brent is once again busy.
He's installing GPUs in Satya's data farm today.
I think it's a long manual process, so he's been keeping pretty busy on that.
So instead I have someone, not 10, not 100, but a thousand times better than Brent.
Someone I've known of for a very long time.
I got a chance to meet maybe 15 years ago for the first time, time flies, maybe
10 years ago.
I don't know.
Time is a drunk slinky.
And someone I've admired for a long time and I'm so excited.
Today we have Elizabeth Hendrickson.
Hi Elizabeth.
Hello.
Time is a drunk slinky.
I am.
I'm totally stealing that in my everyday speech.
That's beautiful.
I say Jeremy, bear me, timey, wimey, but you know.
It makes no sense.
Sometimes it moves fast.
Sometimes it moves slow.
Just I'm sure there's, you know, physics behind it, but whatever.
It's a drunk slinky.
100%.
Well, I'm glad you're here.
How have you been?
What?
I have so many things to talk about.
So let's do some, like just what are you up to now?
What's what's what are you doing today on this wonderful Friday?
Oh, and actually the weather is okay.
Well, it's 35 degrees in Seattle.
Yeah.
What am I doing today?
Well, besides talking with you, I am in the process of sending out copies of for
final review of the manuscript that earlier this week, my co-author, Joel Tosi, and I
just turned in.
So my head is full of nothing but book right now.
And we're going to talk about your book, but I have a path to get us there.
Okay, that's fine.
We may end up the path may be a very short path to write a book for the whole time.
So we will see what happens.
But what's interesting is, and you brought this up first.
Although I think you've taken a much more prestigious route to get there, we've had a
lot of similarity and parallels in our career paths.
And I'll chime in, but I know you started off.
Actually, I don't know how you started off.
Can you can you just give a little history of Elizabeth and software and and kind of
how you came along?
I'm going to chime in with some tangents as we go along.
But I think it's interesting.
And by the way, before we start, because I can't keep a talk together, if you're
listening and you don't know who Elizabeth Hendrickson is, go check it out.
Elizabeth, send me some links and I'll put them in the show notes.
But so just such a body of knowledge.
So much cool stuff.
So many awards and cool stuff.
You're awesome.
And so now I'm done.
So tell me, tell me how did how did how did how did Elizabeth of however many
years ago get to be Elizabeth today?
What was the path like?
Well, in 1980, my dad brought home a TRS 80 machine.
The TRS 80.
Yeah.
Known as TRS 80 at the time and proceeded to basically kind of do the plastics
kid plastics thing from that old movie.
But it was computers, kid computers and had me learning basic.
And and I loved it.
And then a lot of years passed.
Stuff happened.
College like because I was only 13 in 1980 and where I entered the field
professionally and started getting paid to work was actually in tech writing.
Working on writing writing documentation for chips way back in the day.
So about as far away as you can get from what I do now.
Because, you know, tech docs for chips to software cloud.
But a long and windy path that went through QA testing, test automation.
And I think that's where I had started hearing about you.
And so we had heard about each other.
And you heard about me.
Yes, special.
But it was way more than 10 years ago that we met because.
Gosh, I I left Pivotal.
I spent a lot of years at Pivotal, and that's a huge part of my journey
and where I really, truly learned what agile actually is as
opposed to the named methods.
And this is where I think you and I had started discovering that we had
parallel paths even before I went to work for Pivotal.
But I'm pretty sure that the conference that you and I were at predated
Pivotal and I joined Pivotal in 2012.
Oh, gosh. Yeah.
Oh, gosh. Time is a drunk slinky.
Drunk slinky. Right.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
So there's there's so much in there.
Talk to me a little bit because I want to understand the path here.
This is all for me. So listeners, this is all just listening to Elizabeth
and I talk about stuff I'm interested in, so screw you all.
For me, it was a very interesting path.
Although we talked about this before about my path.
I was in and I mentioned this
just for sort of recording.
I'm giving a conversation to a user group in Ukraine next Tuesday.
I'm really excited about my quality as a system for my blog posts.
You'll hear about that.
And then we will talk more about systems later.
And one of the things I leave with is I started in quality for a long time.
I don't need to know my history.
I worked at Microsoft for a while.
I didn't do a lot of testing.
I did a lot of quality work and then moved into infrastructure work
because what I found is when I moved from testing
into platforms and infra, I had far more control over quality.
I could get the CIA gates, I could put put checks in place,
processes in place.
And then I moved more and more into leadership
and higher levels of leadership.
And every level of leadership I got to, I realized I had more,
not just control, but more responsibility over quality.
And the checks I put into place and infrastructure, they help with quality.
But the culture I put into place as a leader,
ten times, a hundred times the the effect on quality.
So I'm curious in your journey from testing to
and we can go on a whole tangent on how agile is misused across the industry.
But in your we can if you want.
But I'm just kind of curious, based on my little story there,
like what was your path like moving into moving from testing through
your path into being, you know,
VP at Pivotal and leadership coach and really kind of getting
the leadership aspect, what was that like for you?
Well, it started with swearing that I was never going to take
another title like director of quality engineering.
So I had a smart move.
Well, but then I did take the title again.
But that's that's like that that's another story.
So from nineteen ninety nine to two thousand one,
I did Silicon Valley bubble dot com startup thing.
For those who are around the valley at the time,
you know how wild a time it was.
It was just I guess I started there in like 98, 1998, 1999.
We're like the height of the Silicon Valley dot com.
The Internet is coming bubble and super wild ride.
I was working for a startup that was running faster than its legs could carry it.
They had quality problems.
They went looking like every like every company betting on AI today.
All right, go on. Yeah. Oh, oh, the parallels.
Oh, oh, my word, the parallels.
But they they did the thing that companies often do
when they have a quality problem.
They're like, well, obviously, the problem is that we don't have somebody
whose job it is to quality.
So we we have tester people.
They report into engineering. They do some testing stuff.
We don't really know what they do.
The end result is bad.
Therefore, what we need is somebody who is the director
or the VP or the pick your favorite title scapegoat scapegoat of quality.
Right. The chief scapegoat of quality, the CSQ.
So I I was naive.
I mean, I had I had at the time had this little consulting company
that wasn't actually consulting.
Really, I did contracting.
I took contracts and I was doing testing on contract.
And I had been in a manager before, but I had never been a director before.
And I end up interviewing for this position.
I end up getting offered the position I joined.
I was so excited for so many reasons.
And about a year later, maybe it was a year and a half, something like that.
My boss, the VP of engineering, hauls me into his office to basically say,
so we have made an enormous investment in quality under your leadership.
You have had us build out a test lab because this was before
Docker was even in.
I remember I remember test labs.
Oh, yeah.
No, we had we had like, I don't know.
It was probably something like 400 square feet that had like
all the different major models of PCs back in the day.
And you could reimage them with this program called Ghost.
But VMS were not a thing.
No, I know. I this is all I very much.
You're having flashbacks right now, aren't you?
Yep. I'm walking down the hall to the lab to see why the computer down
down the road crashed. Yeah.
Uh huh. Yep.
Um, so we we built out a lab.
I hired a bunch of people.
We started trying to invest in test automation.
And so he's saying we've done all of this investment
and our quality is worse.
What are you doing?
And that moment was defining in my career
because I realized it took me a while.
Like, I kind of took the the verbal beating sort of.
And I because I didn't know.
I didn't have an answer at the time.
I'm like, you're right.
Yes. And I have no explanation for you.
So that sent me, though, on a very
a journey of deep introspection that lasted for a couple of months.
As I thought hard about how how how have we gotten here?
And what I realized was was that the better I got at my job,
the worse the software got.
And that is just just so counterintuitive.
How is that?
Which led me actually to where I am right now today,
because the the book that we're not going to talk about yet
is all about systems thinking.
And we're going to talk about the book.
OK, I'm saying plenty of time.
But coming out of that experience, I wrote a paper
called Better Testing, Worse Quality, that talked about the system.
I remember this paper. Yes.
You gave some time. Did you get to have a talk?
Oh, yes. Yes. Yes.
All coming back.
Yeah. So better testing, worse quality.
And at the time, I felt like I was I was kind of speaking
heretical thoughts because this was not the way the industry was going.
But the realization that the the hidden connection,
the the the the backfiring of the system was due to an emphasis
on end of cycle quality activities, end of cycle testing, end of cycle.
Yeah. Well, but I didn't know at the time I I looked at it.
I'm like, we're finding more bugs than ever before.
So how is it that?
And the answer is that back when the company didn't have somebody
with the title and didn't have people who really were
took testing as a profession serious, they took their jobs seriously.
They were smart people.
I'm not criticizing any of them, but it wasn't like a a disciplined,
rigorous, systemic effort.
It was like kind of poking at stuff.
And so everybody on the team, the developers,
were building all kinds of test harnesses to help these testers.
And they were testing and they were finding issues.
And I remember as I was thinking about all of this
and the paper is formulating in my head,
I didn't know I was writing a paper at the time.
I was just writing down notes for myself.
Like, how do we get here?
But I remember reflecting on an event where a developer
attempted to hand me a floppy disk in the hall and said,
here, test this.
And I'm like, what what is this thing that you want me to test?
And it actually in order for that software to get onto the computer
that an end user would experience the software on,
it had to go through our server.
It was signed with a certificate.
It was then vended down from a I don't know if you remember
applications, service providers, ASP is not not the Microsoft ASP technology,
but like we were an application service provider.
This is an old cloud.
Another TLA. Yeah, another.
And so we had this whole server that had to communicate with the client.
You didn't just floppy disk a thing into that that computer.
But that was how far the kind of the distance from the developers
feeling a sense of responsibility for quality had gone
to the point where a developer is like, I'm not even going to bother
putting this on a server the way it needs to go on to a server
to get down to the client.
I'm going to hand you a floppy disk and tell you to test
what's on the floppy.
And, oh, spoiler, it turns out I actually I made him.
I made him deliver it to us the right way.
And when he did, it turns out it wouldn't even load into the server
because it it it violated the rules for how the the software
got onto the server to get sent to the client.
So like we would have tested it and said looks good to us.
And then it would have utterly failed in prod.
Yeah. Yeah.
And it would have been your fault because you have quality in your name.
Of course. Exactly.
You see, you see why I said when I left that job,
I am never taking that title again.
And there's an interesting
like a lot of and you had some maturity with that situation.
A lot of there's a odd codependency, I call it, between testers
and developers in some places or maybe in the past.
I like to think where there are some testers who got that floppy said,
Oh, thank you for giving me this.
I will go test it right now.
Then you'll find some bugs and developers says,
Oh, thank you for finding my bugs.
And the tester feels validated.
It's just not helping anyone worth mentioning.
And we're on our two.
I'll figure out the number later when I post this two hundred
and thirty or so episodes of this podcast.
When Brent and I started it 11 years ago,
it was because 12 years ago now
we saw the changes coming in software in the way it was developed.
And we knew we wanted to just talk about what testers could do
in this new world of quick delivery.
And it isn't trying to do more testing at the end.
And the companies that haven't learned that lesson now up to up to a year ago,
they're in worse shape now because of the speed of AI.
So all so all kinds of screwed up.
That's that's why we're here.
And yeah, really quick story from my end.
I want you to go on.
When I I was a director of platforms at Microsoft when I left
and I went to Unity to be a director of quality,
they I wanted I had always been interested in Unity.
And it was interesting.
And they and they didn't know anything about services.
Well, they knew they knew a bit about services,
but they had a bunch of testers on their services team.
And I said, OK, I'll go I'll go sort this out.
And it it took me
14, 15 months.
But eventually I did dissolve the entire team without laying anyone off.
I found new jobs for everyone as we moved in to develop this.
Like, OK, let's just let's just enable our development team to own quality
and and move it for quick speed.
And there are, as you know, folks out there who would tell us
tell you and I that's irresponsible.
You need to have testers need that.
You need a last line of defense.
You need an advocate for the customers.
And both you and I call B.S. on that.
And anyway, Unity has had their financial problems.
But you're from the stock market, but quality wise,
I think they're still doing pretty well.
Even the engine where it had traditional problems doing better.
But anyway, same sort of thing.
I did it because I thought it would be fun.
And then I got there.
I thought, oh, shoot, I need to work myself out of a job.
And I did. And of course, as you know, once you work out yourself
out of a job, most often there's another job waiting there for you.
Like now there's more stuff you can do.
You've proven you can do something effective and efficient.
So anyway, back to you.
So your journey, you you got out of you.
You were never going to take that role again.
And what would you do next?
Well, what I ended up doing next was going into business for myself.
And I this time, the reboot of the consulting company, same name
quality tree software, which that company doesn't know.
I forgot about I remember the name now because you're not.
You're curious duck now. I'm curious duck now.
I love that name. We'll come back to that in a minute.
But go on. Thank you.
So quality tree.
I rebooted the consulting company in this time.
I actually had enough credentials to do short term
higher value consulting as opposed to doing six month contract.
And I ended up doing a whole lot of speaking, a whole lot of teaching
and somewhere in there because I left that startup.
I think I left actually in in the year 2000 timey wimey.
What is it? I don't know. Drunk Slinky.
But anyway, the point that I left, it was right before
right before the Silicon Valley bubble burst.
And then things went sideways.
But it was also right when this agile stuff was starting.
And Brian Merrick, I give him credit to this day.
He's the one who got me interested in what was happening in the agile community.
He had been saying for a long time, these extreme programming
people are doing really interesting things.
You need to be paying attention.
And at the time, I mean, this was like this would have been two
thousand approximately in the let's see, what was it?
A J unit can't backwrote that.
And I think nineteen ninety nine maybe Snowbird happened in 2001.
So this is all very much at the beginning.
Brian Merrick was at ground zero at the beginning of all of what we now
you know, see as the entire agile movement that happened.
But at the time, I was saying to him extreme.
Uh huh. Bungie cords are involved somehow.
Like, what what is this thing?
And I'm skeptical.
And but then I got the opportunity to Josh
Kerievsky had a class that he invited me to.
We knew each other through the Weinberg community.
And that was immersive XP for an entire week and doing super fast iterations.
It was absolutely mind blowing.
And I kind of did that.
I want to go to their thing.
I want more of that in my life.
So while I was going around giving talks and doing short term training gigs,
in between was looking for opportunities to get more into the agile community.
And I got super lucky.
And I met Rob me at the Austin workshop on test automation that Brett Pettacord
held in I have now forgotten the year, but early super early two thousands.
And he had what was then I think it was called like
Pivotal Computer Systems or something.
But it was the beginning of Pivotal Labs.
And so I started doing contracts with them to understand from an an actual
I'm not just learning about this.
I am on a a product team delivering a thing
and they're practicing extreme programming.
So I did that. So I got so where I went next was to get super immersed
in the agile community, which led to doing a whole lot of agile
transformation training, testing, agile testing, essentially agile testing training.
And that lasted up until in 2012.
Give or take, I finished my book, explore it.
And I realized for a variety of reasons that it was time to close my my practice.
I had built up a studio called Agilistry Studio,
and it was time to close that I was at a crossroads.
And that led to the next chapter.
So what happened next was I went on an agile journey of discovery.
And when was this? Give me a time.
That was like let's call that 2000 to 2012.
OK, and then 2012, the next chapter was pivotal.
OK, but I was contracting off and on with Pivotal Labs.
OK, so they knew you and got in that way. Cool.
You mentioned you want to bring up one little story.
You mentioned that
we first met probably 2012 ish sounds about right.
Give or take.
There's this there's this thing called Stan's Software
Testing Australia, New Zealand.
It's a cool little gig.
If they if they invite you to speak there, they fly you to New Zealand.
You get a day to acclimate and you speak in Christchurch.
Then you go up and speak in Auckland as a day off.
Then you're at two days in Sydney.
And it was fun. Elizabeth and I walked around.
I know we walked around Sydney together to be also walk around.
I think we walked in in Christchurch as well.
I think so. Yeah.
Yeah. And it was it was a fun time.
I do remember
and I don't remember this or not, but I had my last day
was a workshop I gave and I think 2012 was about right. Gosh.
And there was the dinner the night before,
and I ended up hanging out with some other folks.
And I ended up getting back to my hotel room about three
in the morning after after karaoke, being very drunk,
waking up to the sound of the maid knocking on the door
and realized my my talk started in half an hour.
And you were there.
And I remember I remember showering
and getting some clothes on and staggering down to the conference area,
quickly putting some food in myself to settle my stomach
and getting a whole bunch of water and then giving that whole workshop.
Oh, wow.
No, I had absolutely no idea.
And and kudos to you,
because, as I recall, everything you did went well.
So by that time, I had done it a couple of times before.
So I had I had enough real memory and I knew what I was doing.
So, yeah, that's my memory.
That was a not my most shining moment,
but I got through it in a good way.
So that's my and then and then I didn't see again for a few years.
So you you were at Pivotal.
And maybe we're going to get to your book.
Yeah, we're plenty of time.
Walk me through like Pivotal.
You were there for a while. Right. Seven years.
Yes, I was there actually from cradle to grave.
So I had met Rob me done contracts in between going
and like fly around the world and help people and then come back.
And I would I would carve out
like three month chunks of time to work on actual software projects
with Pivotal Labs as a friend of Pivotal.
So I never was a full time employee.
I honestly I I would have jumped at the chance
to join Pivotal Labs full time,
but it just never quite made sense because of reasons.
But when I ended up at this crossroads,
I called up Rob to ask him for advice
and he ended up saying your timing is really weird.
So Pivotal Labs had been acquired by EMC
and they were under the EMC umbrella.
And what Rob knew at that time that I did not know
was that they were about to be spun out again.
And he had a problem.
He had he knew he was going to be responsible for Cloud Foundry
and Cloud Foundry was at the time a VMware thing.
It was going to get spun out with the big spin out
between EMC and VMware spinning out a whole bunch of assets
that didn't make sense in their portfolios,
but would make sense together.
And Rob knew that it had been managed in,
I'm going to say a and I'm I'm you know,
if you're not watching the video on this,
I'm shaking my hand back and forth fairly traditional.
I don't release the video, so they're never going to see it.
Oh, OK. Well, there you go.
I did my hair for no reason. All right. So.
Sorry, you can cut that part out.
No, I leave it all in.
So anyway, it was traditional, not in the the the really old
like 1990s called and wants their process back traditional.
But there was an external QA group
that was kind of separate from the developers.
And Rob knew that he wasn't sure what to do with that.
And so Rob did end up hiring me into the job.
I swore I would never take again.
I was the director of quality engineering for Cloud Foundry.
Yeah. So I joined Pivotal Labs officially on the Monday
after Thanksgiving 2012,
right after my book was was done,
right before the publication date.
Explore it as director of quality for Cloud Foundry
and proceeded to try to find which way is up.
And part of the agreement that Rob and I had
was that I was not going to be building a QA organization
because we all agreed that that is not the way to get quality,
but that I was going to apply all of the systems thinking,
agile understanding that I had to figuring out
how do we actually,
what does a good quality engineering program look like
for a massively distributed system
that's incredibly hard to test?
So that was 2012.
And then in 2019, there was a merger
where VMware purchased Pivotal.
So it had been spun out from VMware,
it returned to VMware.
And that deal closed on the last day of 2019.
I had planned to take some time off after that
because I did not join VMware.
And you will note the year there was 2020.
I had plans for 2020, 2020.
We all did. We all did.
Yeah. So.
And instead we stayed home and we made bread and cocktails.
I actually had started my starter for sourdough
before Thanksgiving 2019
because I knew at that point
that I was going to be taking off a lot of time
and I wanted to be able to have homemade sourdough
at Christmas dinner in that year.
I'm still making homemade sourdough.
Oh, I am not very good at keeping.
It's a wonder I kept my children alive.
I did. And my dogs are fine.
But in general, don't trust me with plants
or sourdough starters.
I killed it. I'm so sorry. It died.
Okay. So we got through the pandemic.
This was more than you wanted to know about me, right?
That's all I wanted to know.
All right. So we're in the pandemic.
We're getting close to now.
And then you have like what happened?
I want to get right up to the book.
So we're almost there.
So what happened after we got through the pandemic?
More consultancy?
Well, I took time off.
I needed to recover from some burnout, honestly.
And then I ended up interviewing for jobs.
But before that, I incorporated a company
just in case somebody wanted to pay me
and I wanted them to be able to pay me.
And I didn't know what the company was going to do
it didn't really have a thesis.
And so hence curious duck
because curious duck could mean anything.
So I had curious duck,
but I ended up interviewing for positions
as a VP of engineering,
ended up taking one of those positions.
We're just not going to talk about that experience.
I lasted five months before I realized
that this really wasn't a fit for any of us.
And it was time for me to go.
And then I decided that I was going to go figure out
how to turn the simulation
that I had been working on into a product.
That failed ultimately for a variety of reasons.
And over time, I've been trying to figure out
what actually is curious duck.
And that's how I ended up back in consulting,
but with a very different spin
this time than quality tree.
Most of my work involves helping organizations
and executives figure out
how to basically treat software development
as the nonlinear system that it is
to unblock software development,
which gets us to the book.
Perfect.
And what is amazing,
we talked about our parallel journey.
So we haven't up until we connected like a month ago,
but up until then we hadn't talked in years.
And independently, we both kind of arrived on this.
So funny.
It's so freaking funny.
I know, right?
Like, hey, quality isn't a role.
And it's also, you can't,
the old thing like the old Mark Mandu quote,
if everyone is responsible for quality,
then nobody is responsible for quality.
And he's kind of right.
And the system, you said before,
the VP, the leader is responsible for quality,
but it's to me, it's the system
that's responsible for quality.
You build a system that will build quality.
And enough about me.
Tell me, let's talk about your book.
What's your book called?
What's it about?
What do people, like all the stuff.
Well, I just realized there is one missing piece
that I kind of forgot to tell you about Pivotal.
I did not keep the title Director of Quality Engineering
because we discovered that all the things
that you and I already know, it was still true.
It didn't really work.
And so I ended up becoming a director of engineering
and then ultimately VP of engineering
and ultimately responsible for our data products,
which is material.
It matters and is important for the book
because it was in that role that I really started
to be able to see the role of two things
that are in the title, the signals and the levers.
So the title of the book is Signals and Levers,
Systems Thinking Tools to Unblock Software Delivery.
Okay, and I wanna-
One system thinking, all right.
Yeah, it's all systems thinking,
all systems thinking all the time.
But I wanna come back to something that you said before.
You said that you realized
as you got up into the infrastructure part
and you were responsible for like the CICD pipelines
that you had more control.
And I wanna push back on you
because that's not what I heard you talking about.
It's not about control.
In a non-linear system, control is an illusion.
You don't control things.
But what you did have were levers.
I did have levers.
I had more levers.
I controlled more levers.
I was in charge of more levers.
Exactly.
Oh, I like this.
Okay, so there's two big categories of levers,
culture and policy.
And so this is why it matters
that I ended up running the entire R&D,
including product and design and engineering.
We are mind melting so hard right now.
Go on. Right.
It matters because this is where I learned
you have two big categories of levers.
You've got culture and policy.
And what I heard you say when you talked about
the control that you had with CICD,
you had policy levers.
So that's why ultimately the head of quality
is in fact the highest position within the organization,
the CEO or whatever the highest title is.
But I have a talk for CTOs
that is modern quality engineering something.
I forget what I call the talk.
And the punchline of the talk is,
hey, even if you've hired a title of quality
who reports up to you, I got news for you.
You are still the head of quality
and you can't get away from that.
And that's because somebody with the title director
of quality doesn't have the policy levers necessary.
They may be able to do a lot with culture.
And we see that with testing on the toilet in Google.
Testing on the toilet was a genius culture move.
Absolutely genius.
And that's a category of lever
but it's not enough by itself.
You need the policy levers also.
And for those of you that don't know,
testing on the toilet was just little ideas
around testing or quality improvements
they put in all the bathroom stalls.
So you have something to read
while you're doing your thing.
Testing on the toilet.
Absolutely genius.
So one way to hit every single employee.
Eventually you will.
It's true.
Yes.
It's funny you mentioned that.
I'm nodding my head because the last newsletter I wrote
and I didn't even realize what I was writing about
completely until you said it is the policy.
You can have policy which many folks can control.
It can be around CICD, it can be around even values.
Like I said, we keep commitments and we value quality
and we escalate risks, but the culture
it's what we reinforce that's the culture part of it.
It's not just having the policy.
You need leadership that reinforces the policy.
What first make sure the policy makes sense
but then reinforce it.
In the case of CICD, it can be,
oh, we had, I'm not going to go up
and talk about flaky tests, but oh, this test failed
but it fails all the time.
It's fine, we'll go on.
So we don't, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know
but it's when you say like, why have the tests
if you're going to ignore someone
when you don't believe them.
What's important in leadership is that you reinforce
if you're going to have a policy,
reinforce the behaviors that support that policy.
As I always say, I'm sure you said before too
celebrate the behavior you want to see.
Oh, a hundred percent.
You and I have have parallel slightly different ways
of saying that I say, feed what you want to grow.
But yes, celebrate the behavior that you want to see,
feed what you want to grow.
That is one of the most important things to do
when you are trying to shape culture
is you ignore the stuff that you don't want.
You don't try to tamp it out
because that's pouring energy into it.
So instead you feed it and you,
and unless it's actively dangerous
and you like need to stamp, tamp it out,
you just ignore the stuff that you don't want,
feed the stuff that you do want
and it grows like a garden.
Yeah, so I turn this back to me and go,
oh, I do this too.
You know, when you read a good book
or a leadership book and by author you respect
and it says stuff that you already do
and you go, oh, I'm validated, I'm validated.
I'm feeling very validated, so thank you for that.
But tell me more about the systems and levers
and what else is in there
because there's more than just that.
Well, I mean, yes, there's more than that.
So my co-author is Joel Tosi
and he, the book started
because he was already teaching a course
called Something Systems Thinking Something
and he was highlighting three key tools,
which are key pillars within the book.
Causal modeling, obviously, like you can't do,
I don't know how to do systems thinking
without thinking about the effects
of aspects of the system or attributes
on the system on one another.
So causal modeling is the thing that allows you
to sort of reason through a situation
like better testing, worse quality,
where, hey, if we increase the emphasis
on testing over here,
what is the impact on that behavior over there?
Causal modeling gives you almost a visual language
to explore those ideas.
So that's a big part of it.
The other thing, two things that Joel brought
that I would never have thought about, honestly,
I discarded the statistical process control stuff
that I had encountered in the 90s
and he was bringing a different lens to it
than I had ever seen before
with the way that he was using Schubert charts
to reason about natural variability
and one of his key points was to look at variability
to make sure that you're not overreacting
to what turns out to be a very natural variability
within your organization,
whether it's variability on things like bug counts
or it's variability on things like cycle time,
that one of the things we see happen a lot
is people start pulling levers
when it's actually super premature
and in the process destabilize a system
that is actually stable
and instead they need to be looking at it
a little bit more holistically
as opposed to special cause,
which is where there were reasons
that we could actually go prevent in the future
from happening.
So his lens on statistical process control
I found really interesting
and it dovetailed so nicely with causal diagrams
because you can now reason
about what are all of the contributing factors
to high variability.
High variability just becomes an attribute
within that causal diagram.
And then the third thing
that he was bringing to the table
that never would have occurred to me
is more of an economics tool,
it's U-curves,
looking for the sweet spot
by mapping the,
we see this as an example of this
would be a batch size,
what is the appropriate batch size in the manufacturing
and you've got one curve
is showing you the holding cost
and another curve is showing you the tear down cost
and so the answer isn't zero or one,
like the smallest batch size
you could do of a thing is one
but that's the wrong answer
because it turns out that manufacturing
the tear down cost is so high
that that would not be the maximum efficiency.
But if you go make seven years worth of a part
in manufacturing,
they will age and fall apart on the shelf
and so you actually will not get the value from it
so you gotta find for your context
what the sweet spot is.
Well, it turns out that that applies
just as well to software
just with different effects affecting costs.
So whether it's,
if you think of how much do we ship
in a given release,
what's our release cadence,
what's our release frequency,
how much are we shipping at a time,
that's an example of a batch size problem
that you curves are the perfect thinking tool
to think through,
what are our costs if we batch up a whole lot?
Well, risk is in there
and the various forms of risk,
not just building the potential
of building bad stuff on top of bad stuff
and not knowing
because we don't have the feedback loop
but also the possibility
that we're just building in the wrong direction
and customers are not gonna want what we've got
and the risk that by the time we actually release,
it's out of date
and we see,
I think we see this in various software projects
over the years,
including, wasn't there like a Duke Nukem game
that by the time it came out?
Duke Nukem forever.
Yeah, took forever, right?
Forever took forever, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So anyway, those are some of the key tools
that are in the book
and then the other thing that we did
was we wanted to make this super approachable
and not overly theoretical
so it is grounded and practical in how-tos
but also we fictionalized all of our experiences
from our combined 60 years
of software development experience,
whatever, however many years it's been
plus all of the stuff that we read about
like the Duke Nukem forever stories, et cetera
and we crammed all of that
into a fictionalized narrative
that runs through the entire book
that shows these characters learning and growing
with the tools over time.
Yeah, but you're learning the mathematical models
to support the or analysis models support these things.
Yes.
I refer to a lot to the,
I use and refer to a lot
my writing the Danela Meadows book
on systems thinking or how they recommend it.
I think it's called Thinking in Systems
and it wasn't until,
I'm just gonna drop a couple of books here
of my favorites,
but the Reinertson Principles of Product Development Flow,
again, like it's one of the books
I'm not a math murder geek,
but like these models make sense
the whole like, what do you call
100% utilized freeway, a traffic jam.
So it's about flow.
And then also a big fan of the Hubbard book
on how to measure anything
which is around confidence levels.
And again, lots of math in there
but it's a way to predict the unpredictable
because you don't try and predict it exactly.
You get a confidence level
and you can work from that and learn from that
because the goal is to make mistakes and learn.
So what I'm really intrigued about in your book
is this, cause I'm a big fan of the narrative fiction.
You know, I just wrote one too.
And I've read like 12 of these narrative fiction books
and I just, I don't know why I like them.
I do.
If you can work in the mathy stuff
and the model stuff that helps people see the system.
You and I see this.
You see teams, we see individuals
complaining about X, Y or Z
and in nearly, in so many cases
they're just not seeing the system.
They're not seeing the bigger picture.
I have a story I could tell, but maybe I will briefly.
I'll just say this.
I read, I don't know if I'm gonna name a name.
Does it matter?
But it very much fits in the systems bit.
I read someone's blog newsletter
or whatever they're called these days.
And it said that the idea that everyone is responsible
for quality is a dangerous term, which I kind of get.
I said, yeah, that doesn't really,
everybody doesn't own it.
Because when everybody does, no one does.
Roles matter.
But localizing responsibility,
like a tester isn't responsible for quality either.
You can have all the best intent
and still ship bad software.
It's not produced and you don't get good quality
by putting much policies into place
that may not be followed.
It's not about slowing down or speeding up
or I'll talk about metrics here in a second.
A lot of these, from what I read on LinkedIn,
I feel like a lot of these testers are set up for failure.
Oh, a hundred percent.
And it makes me sad.
And not only are they set up for failure,
they wanna stay in this role
where they're responsible for quality
and set up for failure.
I'm not against, clear roles I believe in.
For a lot of organizations,
it may make sense to have a tester.
Totally fine with that.
But I'm very much against pretending
that roles are a root cause of quality.
Like, let me give you one more example.
Now I'm talking about metrics and I'll let you talk.
Every time there's some weird,
this drives me crazy.
You know about,
if you read the Decker work on safety systems
like drift into failure,
where a failure isn't the cause of one,
usually these days especially, even in software,
isn't usually one thing.
It's like 10 things went wrong at once.
Going back to the Challenger disaster,
great example of that.
What drives me wild is,
and this is total tangent,
but this is the nature of the podcast,
the crowd strike blue screen thing will come out
or AWS will go down.
And up until a year ago,
they'd always blame the tester.
Oh, if I would have been testing that,
I would have found that.
The tester didn't do their job.
Here's what I would have done if I was testing this.
And now they're blaming AI,
but still they're blaming that.
It's the same thing,
but it's not there.
And you and I know this because we see it as a system.
When these big errors happen that people notice,
it isn't because somebody forgot to test it.
And I just get so,
I've deleted,
I've created an echo chamber
by slowly deleting these folks from my LinkedIn feed.
I spend too much time on LinkedIn
because looking for jobs and all that.
But, and I,
yeah, it's not,
it's because a whole bunch of stuff happened
and you know about none of it.
So. Right.
Oh, a hundred percent.
When people make a mistake,
and it's something I also say often,
when people make a mistake,
it's not because they were malicious.
It's not because they were dumb.
It's because they felt safe making the decision
given the information they had at that time.
And which, if something bad happens,
to me, it's a flaw in the system
and we have to go fix the system that it's in.
Hundred percent.
Absolutely.
I mean, I will say even if somebody
forgot a test case, right?
Like that's still,
that doesn't mean that that is that person's fault.
And I think Deming has been saying this
for really, really long time.
That it's the environment that created the potential
for that one person forgetting
to turn into a disaster of epic proportion.
Yeah. Yeah.
Cause humans are human.
We're fallible.
We're gonna forget stuff.
Exactly. Exactly.
And the story I used to tell a story
I told 20 years ago at a conference
talking about root causes,
I used to lock my keys in the car all the time.
And I got really good at opening my car
with a coat hanger.
But then I got a car after that,
and that car,
it was impossible to lock the keys in the car.
The car wouldn't lock if the keys were inside.
So the system, I mean,
people are gonna make errors.
Somebody said, okay, spy's a dummy.
We're going to make it
so he cannot lock his keys in the car.
He can make different mistakes instead.
Dude, I'm so sorry to tell you
this wasn't just about you.
Ask me about the time I locked the keys
in a rental car while the car was running
and I had to call AAA.
I don't need to ask you,
you just told the story.
That was mortifying.
Oh yeah.
And I was double parked
cause I was only stopping for a moment.
Yep. I've done that.
I did that before, haven't I?
Yeah.
So anyway,
so excited about the book.
Narrative fiction,
models around systems thinking to,
and so what are examples of some levers?
What are some of the levers
to talk about in the book?
I want to talk about the tiniest levers
cause this is the last edition before,
or sorry, the last audition,
not addition,
audition before the manuscript
left our hands to go to copy edit,
which there's this whole funnel
of activity that goes from idea
to there are dead trees with your words printed on them
that you can,
like there's this whole funnel.
And one of the critical points
in that funnel to dead trees
is the handoff to copy edit.
And I snuck in one last change under the wire
and it was about a lever.
In talking with somebody,
I realized that they were telling a story
about declining a meeting.
A lever is any decision that you make.
And sometimes the tiniest decisions
actually have a huge outsized impact.
And so just the act of declining a meeting
that is going to be a waste of your time
is in fact pulling a lever on the system.
You're not,
you're refusing to feed
the time wasting way premature
or 9 million people in their friends
are all invited to the same meeting.
I call it being CC'd on a meeting.
Exactly.
So the big levers that we think of
are things like the policy lever,
like you can't merge your code
until it's passed the pipeline and is green
or we never ship on red or whatever.
Those are big levers.
And they're levers that you need
organizational authority,
formal authority to enact those levers.
There are levers that are purely cultural.
Like one of my wins at Pivotal,
we were having trouble with long cycle times
in the test pipeline itself.
Like the tests took forever.
They were often flaky.
And I remember talking with somebody,
an engineer, I was in VP role.
I'm talking with a team.
One of the engineers said something about,
oh, it's just gonna take so long to clean that up
and is it really worth it?
And we're talking about this.
And I realized that we had a culture problem
where there was just not this cultural belief
that it was important to have tight,
reliable feedback cycles within the pipeline.
And I don't remember how this came up,
but I basically said, hey, look,
if you can cut the execution time down,
if you can lop an hour or two
off of the execution time in the pipeline,
I'll make you a pie.
And I make good pie.
Oh, I often think what I need to do for a pie myself.
Anyway, go on.
Well, I will make you a pie if we're ever in the same city.
I don't think it's gonna ship very well
from where I am to Seattle.
So this person said, I like pie.
Everyone likes pie.
And within a couple of weeks,
he'd done this thing that he'd been
really resisting doing
and lopped a couple of hours off of the runtime.
And I made him a pie.
And I brought it to stand up.
It was a very public transference of pie.
It was a whole pie.
He's holding this pie in the homemade dish
and with the crust and the drips and everything.
And other people are looking at him and saying,
what did you do to get pie?
And of course, I turned this into one
of the best slides ever when I gave this example
in the talk that I give
on care and feeding of feedback cycles,
that it's the pipeline.
Ah, I get it.
But in all seriousness, it was a real thing.
It wasn't just for the jokes.
It became a tradition.
And this is a culture lever.
Now, did the culture lever carry more weight
because the VP hand baked a pie?
I don't know.
I will never know.
No one will ever tell me.
But I will tell you, it became such a thing
that at one of our other offices, our office in Oregon,
I was visiting and they had done a lot of work
on the pipeline and the director of engineering there
said, so we got to talk about pie.
And I'm like, but Oregon, and I'm staying at the Hilton,
like, how do you expect me to pie?
And he said, I have a kitchen.
And so this is how I found myself
at the home of the director of engineering.
Anthony, thank you so much.
Or sorry, God, no, that's really embarrassing.
We have to cut that because it was Alexander Merman.
It's staying in.
It all stays in.
Okay, well, Anthony, I adore you,
but you didn't let me use your kitchen.
We had two directors of engineering.
Alexander Merman, thank you for letting me use your kitchen.
It was delightful.
This is how I ended up showing up at his door
with all of the ingredients for pie.
Plus he said, we never make pie,
so we don't have any pie dishes.
I'm like, all right, no problem.
I know where to get those.
So like I had all of the supplies
and we made pie for like five hours
so that we could bring it into the office
and reward everyone with pie.
So you asked, coming back to your question,
when you asked about levers,
levers can be extremely surprising things.
Sometimes it is baking a pie.
It is everything you do to feed the culture
that you wanna grow.
It is every decision that you make.
It is every policy that you have put in place.
They're all levers.
The problems happen when we pull levers
in the wrong sequence,
or we pull the lever that is most obvious
and closest to us,
but actually has nothing to do.
Because we haven't looked at the system.
Where the pain was actually being caused.
So engineering is this,
software delivery is this huge, big thing.
Massive, yes.
Everything's connected.
You can't just flip levers randomly.
100%.
And here's the one I love.
I know we're running out of time,
but like I know what we need to do.
We need to make a dashboard with the Dora metrics.
Then we'll be good.
Yeah, sure, because that'll fix it.
Visibility is absolutely a lever.
I know, but-
But it might not be the right lever in the moment.
Yeah, you need, and this is the point I hope,
and I hope that a lot of leaders read this book
because you need to think about
the full system you're trying to manipulate
and not just trying to react.
You need to think about what everything does.
And then, and again, go back to, you know,
reinforced behavior you want to see.
Feed the, feed the food.
What was it?
Feed what you want to grow.
I knew my translation didn't make any sense.
Feed the food is weirdly,
well, I mean, you know,
non-linear systems are adaptive and non-linear
because feedback is-
I think I was still thinking about
sourdough starter where you are feeding the food.
You are, yeah, it's true.
I subconsciously, it was there.
All right, oh my God, I want another hour to talk to you.
Well, we can make that happen.
You could come on my podcast.
Spoiler, spoiler, I've agreed to do that.
I can't wait.
Woo!
Yeah, we can talk some more.
Elizabeth, it is great to catch up with you.
You are amazing.
And I'm so excited for this book to come out.
When does it come out?
Release date, September,
maybe September 22nd, we think,
and pre-sales March.
Cool, very cool, awesome.
I can't wait.
All right, I think we better get going here,
but thank you so much for being here.
Thank you.
You are a much better Brent than Brent.
It was great catching up with you.
I can't wait to read the book.
I can't wait to hear more.
I want to know so much more about what you've been up to,
but we'll talk more soon.
All right, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Bye.